ليس من المستغرب
أن أوضح الرئيس ترامب أنه لا
يقبل بالتأكيد أنه خسر وأن جو بايدن
قد فاز في الانتخابات ،
دعنا نذهب إلى البيت الأبيض و cnn's
jim acosta كما تعلم جيم كنا ننظر فقط
إلى نوع من اللقطة الجوية
هناك.  يمكن أن يرى الناس يتجمعون
خارج الرئيس من الواضح أنهم كانوا في
ملعب الجولف عندما اكتشف ذلك
والآن
أه عائدًا أخبرني بما تراه
هناك ما يحدث
آه آرون إنه مشهد رائع هنا
في البيت الأبيض يمكنني أن أخبرك أننا  لقد
كنت هنا طوال الصباح طوال فترة ما بعد الظهيرة
ويمكنك سماع الاحتفالات
القادمة من شوارع واشنطن
حول أرض البيت الأبيض
التي سمعناها طوال اليوم
أنك تشاهد هذه الصور الحية في
الوقت الحالي
لحياة سوداء مهمة
حشد خارج
الكنيسة الأسقفية في سانت جون ، من الجدير
بالذكر لمشاهدينا آرون بالنسبة لأولئك
الذين لم
يكتشفوا هذا بالفعل بأنفسهم ، فهذا
هو نفس المشهد حيث كانت الإدارة
قاسية  استخدم المتظاهرون الذين تم تطهيرهم من
الغاز المسيل للدموع مثل المواد الكيميائية على
المتظاهرين
لتطهير تلك المنطقة حتى يتمكن الرئيس من
التقاط الصور حيث
رفع الكتاب المقدس
أمام تلك الكنيسة مرة أخرى في يونيو
الأول أه الآن هو مشهد
احتفال
أه أعني أنه  إنها إحدى التغريدات
التي قد تراها هناك كيف بدأت
كيف تسير الأمور ، أعني أن ذلك
يرسم الصورة الآن
الصورة الأخرى يمكننا أن نعرضها لك هنا
في شوارع واشنطن في الشارع السابع عشر
متجهًا نحو مجمع البيت الأبيض
لقد قامت المخابرات الأمريكية بتطهير
تلك المنطقة
حيث سيصل موكب الرئيس
قريبًا ، لذا
سيعود إلى البيت الأبيض ، هذا هو المكان المناسب ، وسيعود إلى
البيت الأبيض في الدقيقتين القادمتين
إلى  مشهد لمدينة تحتفل
برحيله وهو الآن
الرئيس المنتهية ولايته للولايات المتحدة
الآن بالطبع بالطبع
دونالد ترامب لا يرى الأمر بهذه الطريقة فقد
أصدر بيانًا في وقت سابق
اليوم بعد  تم إعلان أن جو بايدن هو
الفائز أه
هو لا يقبل أن جو بايدن
قد فاز في هذه الانتخابات ولسنا بحاجة
للقراءة من هذا البيان فهو
مليء بالمزيد من نفس
المعلومات الخاطئة التي كنا نراها
من الرئيس
في تغريداته  وهكذا أه لكنه
يقول إن فريقه يقول إنهم
سيبدأون في رفع
بعض هذه الاعتراضات القانونية بدءًا من
يوم الاثنين للاعتراض على نتائج هذه الانتخابات
في هذه الولايات المختلفة ، لكن يمكنني
إخبارك بالتحدث إلى مستشاري ترامب الأشخاص
داخل
لا يمكن لحملة الرئيس أن توجهنا إلى أي دليل على تزوير الناخبين. لقد
تحدثت إلى أحد
المستشارين في وقت سابق من هذا الصباح الذي
لم يقل شيئًا ملموسًا ليس لدينا أي شيء
ملموس من شأنه توجيه
أي قاضٍ في هذا الشأن إلى أي
حالات تزوير في التصويت ، وبالتالي فإن
الرئيس الآن
هو  يلعب بيد خاسرة ، لقد كان
خارج ملعب الجولف
طوال اليوم محاولا بشكل أساسي
تجنب المشهد الذي يعود إليه
الآن